you know the super nice record-breaking
displays on Apple's iPhones well they're
actually using display panels directly
from Samsung display a subsidiary of
Samsung Electronics which is known to be
Apple's biggest rival but now in 2023 it
looks like apple is finally ready to
break up with Samsung and move on so in
this video I'm gonna get into exactly
what this means for the future of the
iPhone is it a good thing or a bad thing
and then I'm gonna explain how this sort
of thing is actually becoming a trend
for apple with them ditching other big
suppliers and of course I'm gonna
explain why so let's jump right into it
a new report from Nikkei Asia claims
that apple is going to mass produce its
own micro LED displays for iPhones which
means that they're ditching Samsung in
order to have more control over the
supply chain and according to their
sources Apple has spent at least a
billion dollars on micro LED research
and development over the past decade and
that true because you can find
incredibly old Apple patents concerning
micro LED technology now to me this is a
huge deal because for the past few years
iPhone displays have been so similar to
the ones from Samsung flagships that
it's almost funny and that's because the
panel is basically the same so because
of Apple's Reliance on Samsung there's
really no way to shine in terms of
display quality no pun intended it's
basically just a back and forth
regaining and losing the title of the
world's best smartphone display and it's
pretty obvious but now Apple has other
plans and it's all going to depend on
micro LED technology which involves
placing at least tens of thousands of
tiny micro LED chips onto substrates and
if you don't really know how micro LED
compares to regular OLED or AMOLED
smartphone displays there are many more
LEDs that together can get much brighter
while being more efficient and at the
same time not having the same burn-in
issues as regular OLED displays and the
contrast of the display will be much
better so it's essentially a massive
win-win-win from all angles in terms of
display Tech and that's Apple's goal
with this new technology not only that
but this will give Apple's iPhone A
major advantage over other smartphones
these displays are going to be exclusive
to the iPhone and very hard for the
competition to copy and follow this
means that the iPhone will have the best
display in any smartphone for likely
years on end without losing that title
but even further it'll put Apple in
control of the supply chain so they can
be sure to plan ahead without any
shortages it'll also put Apple in
control of the specs and upgrades so
they can put these displays on an
upgrade timeline without relying on
Samsung to do it for them and finally
it's going to greatly improve Apple's
profit margins on their disc displays
since they don't have to pay Apple
retail or wholesale price for the panels
which of course includes some extra
profit in Samsung's pocket instead
Apple's gonna partner up with osram for
micro LED components LG display for
these substrates and tsmc for the 12
inch silicon Wafers it'll essentially be
just like Apple's a series chips which
are designed by Apple but they use
Wafers from tsmc memory from other
companies like Samsung and Micron and
they get assembled by Foxconn however we
do have a bit of a problem but first
I've got to give a shout out to our
partner case Q for their magic stand
case which is the most versatile case
I've ever used due to the fact that it
has a completely flush Max a freeing on
a hinge so you can use it as a stand for
things like watching videos or taking
photos at a variety of angles in the
case itself is super rugged in high
quality as well and now Casco is
offering a new payment method so you can
shop now and pay overtime with clarna so
check out the discount info and Link
down in the description below now
getting back to the micro LED display
Apple's already invested a billion
dollars into this technology and we
still don't have iPhones with these
displays so when is it actually coming
well it looks like apple will debut this
micro LED technology on the Apple watch
Ultra either in 2024 or
2025 which makes sense because it's got
the smallest display out of any Apple
product and then only after that will
they bring it to the iPhone how long
exactly well the easiest way to tell is
to look at what Apple has done in the
past the first Apple watch with an OLED
display came in 2015 and then two years
later in 2017 is when we got the first
iPhone with an OLED display so so
because of that I would guess that the
iPhone will be getting a new micro LED
display in
2027 and I have a very good reason for
that first of all Apple's iPhones are on
a three-year redesign cycle we got a
redesign with the iPhone 6 and 2014 then
with the iPhone 10 in 2017 and then the
squared off iPhone 12 in 2020 and now in
2023 we're getting another redesign with
USBC and rounded edges on the frame but
the interesting thing is that Apple
sometimes Waits another year after a
redesign to give some display upgrades
like the iPhone 13 Pro which got the 120
hertz Pro motion refresh rate feature a
year after the iPhone 12 redesigned and
we already have rumors of next year's
iPhone 16 Pro Models getting upgraded
6.3 and 6.9 inch displays a year after
the expected iPhone 15 Pro redesign so
unfortunately it looks like we'll be
waiting another four years until the
micro LED display comes to the iPhone
but we might only have to wait a year to
get a sneak peek of this technology on
the Apple watch Ultra but now I want to
jump into how Apple isn't only planning
to break up with Samsung but also even
more companies first of all Apple
already broke up with Intel to make
their own ships which was probably the
most important change Apple has made in
many years giving Apple a huge exclusive
lead in terms of performance efficiency
and battery life but as soon as next
year apple is expected to finally ditch
Qualcomm and its 5G modem that Apple has
been relying on for some time now and
they're going to be making their own
in-house custom 5G modem which will
likely be much more efficient than the
previous ones there's even talks of
Apple potentially using their own
Bluetooth and why Wi-Fi chips and all of
that is going to help them save on
profit margins and I think that's the
ultimate goal prices of smartphones have
been going up and up and despite all of
that and inflation Apple has been able
to keep the price of the iPhone 14 pro
at 999 dollars which is super impressive
but it's getting harder and harder by
the year in-house custom chips and
components will really help Apple stay
competitive and keep their profit
margins as high as possible and all of
that is going to keep everyone happy
including their investors but now let me
give you my opinion on all of this I
personally am super excited for these
new micro LED displays because I know
they're going to look incredible while
improving battery life which is always
welcomed and frankly I'm sick of every
flagship phone out there having
basically the same display with no real
differences between the the iPhone and
the flagship Samsung phones I think I'm
ready for something different and
special with my iPhone instead of It
sharing the same panels with other
phones sort of like how the mini LED
display on the 12.9 inch iPad Pro
compares to other tablets with low
brightness OLED displays and I'm
honestly really excited for the updated
5G modems and potential Bluetooth and
Wi-Fi chips since Apple doesn't have to
wait on anybody else to adopt the latest
technology they can just pack it in
since they have full control over the
design and everything else so I think
we're on a New Horizon of Apple's
iPhones getting better and better
compared to the competition matching the
same special feel that you get with an
apple silicon Macbook so there you guys
go let me know what you think about
Apple ditching their current Partners
down in the comment section below and if
you enjoyed the video click the circle
above to subscribe for more videos like
this one thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next video
foreign